if you really believe continue to do it
always believe belief in what you're
doing
what's that believe nation at seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode it
under the world now I started the one
world series because we do a lot of top
tens and there's some rules that come up
over and over and over again and so the
idea is to take the most common rules
that keep coming up and smush them
together into one video for you guys so
today we're gonna learn how to never
stop believing in joy in the past
eighteen years when I do internet in
China we've got a criticism every day
you know something will you believe it a
lot of people criticize it but if you
really believe continue to do it improve
it we were rejected by more than 30
venture capitalists but we are very
optimistic we believe in the future we
believe in Internet and we believe that
if we do not succeed
somebody will create the highest
grandest vision possible for your life
because you become what you believe when
I was a little girl
Mississippi growing up on the farm only
Bukka weed is a role model watching my
grandmother boil clothes and a big iron
pot through the screen door because we
didn't have a washing machine and made
everything we had
I watched her and realized somehow
inside myself and the spirit of myself
that although this was segregated
Mississippi and I was colored and female
that my life could be bigger greater
than what I saw I remember being 4 or 5
years old I certainly couldn't
articulate it but it was a feeling and a
feeling that I allowed myself to follow
I loud myself to follow because if you
were to ask me what is the secret to my
success
it is because I understand that there is
a Power greater than myself that rules
my life and in life in life if you can
be still long enough in all of your
endeavors the good times the hard times
to connect yourself to the source I call
it God you can call it whatever you want
to the force nature Allah the power if
you can connect yourself to the source
and allow the energy that it is your
personality your lifeforce to be
connected to the greater force in the
thing is possible for you I am proof of
that I think that my life the fact that
I was born where I was born
and the time that I was and have been
able to do what I've done speaks to the
possibility not that I am special but
that it could be done biggest risk
you've ever taken I completely changed
the course of my life in career when I
discovered this thing called the Y I
abandoned what I was doing and said I
want to do that and people thought I was
crazy they thought I went out of
business but I was so I believed in it
so much I have to caution into the wind
I think Y has been the key my whole life
the wood why it's it's it's a little kid
question that we grow out of here some
reason when you launch quests there were
sixteen hundred other protein bar
companies that launched in 2010 Lavers
or companies or companies yeah what gave
you the audacious mindset to think that
you could compete against all those plus
the 10 20 years of other nutrition
companies out there and beat them
yeah it's I'm having any experience in
this yeah I'm gonna give you a phrase
that I play in my own head that I know
and I say out loud 50 percent of people
love and 50 percent of people hate me
for it but it's true so hey here we go I
have the arrogance of belief I believe
in myself no I believe in one thing
about me I am not the smartest guy I got
a 990 on my SATs I took it twice
that's my combined score that's bad for
both of us
I was joking people a monkey smearing
feces on the test could score higher
than I did like it's literally terrible
yeah but I always believed that I could
do whatever I set my mind to right so
that's the only the only credit I will
give myself is when other people break
and give up and stop
I just don't write and it comes down to
the story you tell yourself about
yourself and that's the story I tell
myself it was just this last weekend I
was at an entrepreneurial organization
and they brought a world-class mountain
biker in and said hey anybody that wants
to go for a ride with her go and I
thought okay you know I'll go and and
cuz she's saying we can do a beginner
course or whatever I thought was perfect
now jump on the bike and go I've never
been on a mountain bike before ever in
my life
I've been on a bike of any kind probably
in 15 years that was probably stupid and
we're in God's Sun Valley Idaho so it's
not exactly flatland and we go mountain
biking and I'm dying I'm just done it's
it like 6,000 feet first of all so I can
match my breath and I keep stopping and
everyone's like yeah you know you took
hey man like go ahead and turn back it's
all good it's all good and I'm like I
don't think you know the story I tell
myself like there's no universe in which
I stop so I keep going finally they've
done the loop right some people have
turned back whatever they've done the
loop and now they're coming back and
they're passing me I'm still headed out
and they're like you need to turn around
and I'm like I'm so sorry but I'm not
gonna turn around and they said okay but
then we're no longer responsible for you
and I was like oh okay I like it is what
it is man I appreciate that no worries
I'm a big boy like go and I just kept
going and I must have come in an hour
and twenty minutes or something after
everybody else but I finished and that
meant so much to me I was like I'm gonna
ignore the fact I got my ass handed to
me and I came in dead last yeah yeah but
I'm gonna be proud that I didn't quit
interesting did you say arrogance of
belief is that we said arrogance of
belief we've made a huge number of
mistakes along the way right now I I
always say I just think we've made
probably every possible mistake you
could make
they're a decision that you've made that
the people around you told you was a
mistake
and you defied them and you were right
you know I mean the most famous one I
think probably has to do with selling
the company right I mean in 2006 right
we're this opportunity to sell the
company to Yahoo for a billion dollars
and we we turn that down I think a lot
of people at the time thought that we
should sell the company but you know I I
felt really strongly and I think like
now people generally think that that was
a good decision a lot of people who I
think build startups their companies
think that's selling the company or
going public is this end point right
it's like you win when you go public and
that's just not how I see it it must
feel good when you can say I told you
definite what does that title mean
exactly that yeah the feeling of I told
you I know that's kind of how I felt
about my music for years you know I felt
like my music is it may have not been
the greatest but it was at a level that
was higher than a lot of people you know
at least the quality of music that a lot
of people were putting out and all
throughout the times that I've been
putting out music you know match the
times they've been putting out music
right and so I've always kind of felt
like you know one day somebody has to
see this you know and for all the people
that I told it and he just doubted me
and like time after time when I'm
sitting there I'm just like you'll
please just believe me and everyone just
looked at me and just it's like I don't
see it hmm you know and and and no
matter what I would explain to them
y'all I'm gonna do this and I'm gonna do
this like this and I even you know
despite the times when I was homeless
and I was sleeping in the back of cars
trying to figure it out and telling
people like just listen to what I have
you know I mean I'm tugging it out going
to the studio every single night
sleeping in my car not even my car just
somebody's car along weren't you
homeless story I I was like I was almost
every time yeah yes several times two
different times in my life the first
time I was homeless fight two months
second time I was homeless for like not
long two to three weeks
man it was a long-ass day you don't have
nowhere to go those those nights and
those days are longer than anything and
so when you say I've told you it's not
like man like you know it's like man
yeah it's like it's totally like I told
you guys like like this is really like I
want you to know I told you that I would
be I told you that one day before they
try to sweep up albums and 40 try to
sweep up CD real physical sales I will
have something on a shelf I told you
it's not that you you know prove what
you have to prove to yourself for them
you do that right right right but you
also do have something to prove to them
yeah well always tell me how did you I
say man it proving me right at the same
point I'm proving you wrong you don't
know saying so so I believe in me you
don't it's crazy because even when you
get on to where you say man and you know
you know me I'm signed here it it's
about the happening and there's certain
things don't happen you get people that
also count your failures like man I
thought oh four you even get to a point
you stop telling people what's your
plans all that's true they don't I think
I've experienced that a lot of times
just being in places where like you know
I've had a lot of you we were daring
when you thought something was hot and
then it didn't pop and then instead of
like recouping back with us and
believing like all right let's come with
the next plane it's just a fall off so
I've had to deal with so many people
falling ride and off them the trail and
the track and so that I told you is to
them to it doing what I do you know
acting it's not just acting it's you
know what goes into becoming an actor
people see the end result I see the
lights to see the premieres I see the
movies they don't see the time that you
put in by yourself they don't see the
the lonely journey they don't see the
moments where you're sleeping in your
car the moments you stay up all night
and you're studying these lines
rehearsing you know and then you
to audition you don't get it but somehow
you still have faith and believe that
you're doing is supposed to be doing so
I was super poor sometimes we sometimes
we don't right I was sure as you see I
was still short
I was a farm boy and I was a dog boy and
the dog boy was actually at barreto
which America Loretto it was in
something positive it wasn't something
that you should celebrate it was a kid
this smells like dog the house fleas or
ticks that's their perception so I went
through that in my childhood right
because those were following me I didn't
know why but dogs followed me but the so
people would go after me yes because
they'll follow me yeah was that saying
mean things to me then in my adolescence
stage though still follow me I'll still
be called Potrero
I was super sure I'm still short I was
not here at all and I was not popular at
all then I came to America and in
America
I was called an immigrant which I was
right I was homeless I how place to live
so I lived in the street for two months
and then I speak no English but it got
better it got better because I stay
focused on what I really wanted for me
to happen I wanted to be the best dog
trainer in the world I was 13 years old
when I told my mom mom you think I can
be the best doctor in the world and she
believed that means she says yes you can
be whatever you want and that's really
what we need to attach itself now what
somebody else might see on us you know
all the negativities that they want to
ask they want us to pay attention to yes
I was poor but not from the heart not
from the mind right so so what I did is
I got so what I did is I got hold of the
people that believed in me and thus that
was very important for it for for and
that was very important to me I don't
like to use the word success but I just
like to use the word I accomplished
something because I believed in me
because God willing to me everybody
hasn't yet
I don't think I'm the only human in the
world that has to give everybody has
their own special gift so I just want to
let you know you know that sometimes
when somebody sees something different
than you it's actually a gift it's a
gift that they don't have I was saying
you know they kick you when you down but
they want to kick it when you up you're
saying and and I just believe like you
know my whole journey in life is like
I've always been told no and I always
took them knows and turn them to yes um
saying and I always believed in my path
to my vision even though I know you have
to go through trials and tribulations in
life but I do know the sunshine on the
other side you know I do know there's a
goal there's a victory you're saying
winning ain't easy success don't come
overnight this is 25 years of blood
sweat tears they were saying before I
got on this show before I made a number
one record before jay-z became one of my
partners you know saying this is like
you know never surrender never giving up
never stopping you're saying and some
days it was real stormy and I made it
through it you know you know what if you
learn from your success so far
maybe that's all about hard hard work
anything and trusting in what you're
doing because in the beginning there
were a lot of people like you know
Morton you're too young
it's not gonna work and also had my my
soccer team there I was I was DJing
there like and right now they're like oh
dude you're right then I think that's
this and the most important thing if you
believe in what you're doing is like
that's the most important thing if you
don't believe in what you're doing you
can give it you you give up you and then
you don't have to put time and effort in
because it won't work
now I've got a very special Gary
Vaynerchuk bonus belief clip for you
that you're really gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know what did you take from this
video how are you going to believe in
yourself more what message resonated the
most with you give me your feedback
please leave it down the comments below
would mean a lot to me thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clip
the way I do branding I sell so
infrequently that I think some of you
that are watching me the hardest core
need to hear this which is it's ok to
sell especially if you believe in
something look if you believe in what
you're selling and that's what I'm
spending a lot of time on now trying to
spend more time on really getting to a
place where I really believe in stuff
instead of just passive not creating so
I wasn't selling because I didn't
believe you know and just letting
everything come to me but as I create
these you know events Vayner experiences
a lot of events very big on events
events are so valuable just watching the
four DS crew its value and like how it's
impacting their business for ten
thousand dollars right their game and
you see I know you get the emails the
wine club like $150 worth one for fifty
five bucks like I've just locked in
November's it's gonna make all your
Thanksgivings ridiculous the conference
$500 two-hour session in my stomping
grounds a good deal compared to like
other conferences that I speak at but
you're getting the wine for free or
you're getting the talk to free and
you're getting the wine so like I'm very
fascinated because I'm putting more
pressure on myself to create things that
I really believe in which then allows me
to sell more and I just think for a lot
of you selling the ask the right hook is
very difficult you're passive you like
the idea of like feeling good about like
giving out content this and that when
you believe in something you can sell it
and you should put more pressure on
yourself to create things that you
believe in biggest problem is so many of
yourself you don't believe in you're
just doing it for the money you're gonna
lose that I don't like if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you up or so it
would be like a little beacon table
Ignatian if you want to know what the
most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
[Music]